hallo ja ich habe eure Nachrichten
bekommen du hast in diesem Video voll
Ähnlichkeit mit Jenna Ortega die von
WinCE day Vanessa sieht aus wie Vince
day hättest du ein Pony und zwei Zöpfe
dann siehst du aus wie Wednesday sie ist
tatsächlich ein bisschen aus wie winstay
winstay bist du's du erinnerst mich vom
Aussehen her einfach so krass an die
Wednesday von Netflix
ich sehe aus wie Wednesday Adams
[Musik]
aber ja ich weiß was ihr meint da ist
irgendwie eine Ähnlichkeit da und
deswegen style ich mich heute zu
Wednesday Adams
und ich hoffe ich tue euch damit
irgendwie einen Gefallen und am besten
fangen wir mit dem Make-up an um das
Make-up von westday Adams rauszufinden
gehen wir auf unsere Lieblingsseite
Pinterest da schaue ich wirklich immer
nach wenn ich irgendein Make-up für
irgendein Halloween Kostüm oder sonst
was brauche
Adams also sie hat schon eine sehr helle
Haut oder hier ist die gute dieses
Make-up versuchen wir nachzumachen es
sollte ja wohl nicht so schwer sein ich
denke mal die dunklen Lippen und ja ganz
leichte Smokie Eis und eine ganz helle
Haut das sind so ihre
Alleinstellungsmerkmale Haut hat sie ja
gar nicht ne also ich habe Wednesday
erst viel später geschaut als alle
anderen ich habe da irgendwie nicht
gedacht dass das eine gute Serie ist als
ich dann aber angeschaut habe zehn von
zehn und das aller schlimmste ich habe
die Serie angefangen zu schauen ob es
auf Instagram gepostet und habe dann in
den dmsen paar Nachrichten gelesen er
hat einfach eine Person den kompletten
Plot Twist in einem Satz und nicht mal
so hahaha ich Spoiler dir das jetzt nein
bist du dumm bist kann es sein kann es
sein kann es sein also habe ich in der
zweiten Folge schon ganz genau gewusst
ja was da am Ende quasi der große Twist
ist es hat mich so genervt ich glaube
ich hätte die Serie so viel besser noch
gefunden wenn ich das nicht gewusst
hätte war furchtbar lustiges auch wenn
ich aussehe wie Wednesday fühle ich mich
eher wie ihre Mitbewohnerin also vom
Charakter
mit dem Concealer wird nicht gespart bei
den Augenbrauen machen wir jetzt nichts
Besonderes einfach nur schmal nachziehen
das benutzt winstation bestimmt auch
jeden Morgen schönes Gel für meine
Augenbrauen weiter geht's mit den Augen
und dem spaßigsten Teil erstmal diesen
Farbton hier oben das ist meine Toilette
ich bin mir sicher dass wenn's day die
Farbe Jet Setup benutzt
sie denn dann morgen zu meinem Zimmer
mit ihrem schlechten Laune schminkt sich
erstmal mit der Tablet Palette gespannt
wie ich am Ende aussehen wenn ich dieses
Jahr nach Köln fahre könnte ich so auch
in Karneval dann rumlaufen denken dass
ich die echte bin also sie hat jetzt
diesen einen bräunlichen Ton hier vorne
am Auge doch ja das ist der Look die
Kleine hat sogar
mehr Dynamik reinzubringen nämlich meine
neue
Palette mit der ich super und zufrieden
bin ich habe sie bei Douglas im Angebot
gekauft und es hat sich überhaupt nicht
gelohnt also die Farbe ist ganz cool und
die hier
ja aber irgendwie wundert mich nicht
dass sie im Angebot war
gut zusammen
gehe ich jetzt noch mal hier direkt
unter Wimpernkranz jetzt gehe ich noch
in den oberen Wimpernkranz entlang
Palette die Farbe Case Claus und closen
hier oben mal ab der hat aber auch mal
ein bisschen anderen Lippenstift ich
glaube morgens im Badezimmer
experimentiert sie auch manchmal der
gute kajal-pan von Essence den ich seit
300 Jahren habe
also
einen kleinen Schwung hat noch niemanden
euer lieblings Charakter aus meinem stay
schreibt gerne in die Kommentare
eigentlich würde ich gerne über den
Inhalt der Serie sprechen aber ich will
es halt auch niemanden Spoilern wo wir
uns Mühe geben müssen ist beim face
contouring anscheinend sehe ich ja schon
bisschen aus wie sie aber ich bin
natürlich noch meine Gesichtszüge
Personen dass sie noch mehr aussehen wie
Problem ist nämlich das Wednesday sicher
zehn Kilo weniger wiegt als ich dann
gehe ich jetzt in mein contouring Powder
ich liebe es dass ich auch immer noch
ein Make-up Tutorial daraus mache halli
hallo meine Lieben konturiere noch mal
ein bisschen nach mit diesem contouring
weil das ist sehr deckend
und dann gehen wir noch mal drüber so
der Mund ist sehr wichtig kein muss ich
sagen genau tegern ich habe wirklich die
gleiche Lippenform da muss ich einfach
nur Nachfahren Farbe die ich gekauft
habe ist zu Kirsche und das hier ist so
ein Tattoo Farbe ich habe sie ein
bisschen zu herzig gemacht haha die
dürfen unten nicht so spitz zu laufen
die müssen eher so gerade mein Make-up
ist somit fast fertig wir machen weiter
mit den Haaren problem Nummer 1
Pony ja ich schneide mir für dieses
Video noch ein extremeren Pony als dass
ich wäre aber ja nicht Vanessa wenn ich
nicht paar Teile hätte um meine Haare zu
verlängern damit wir dann Flechten
können und sie dann so richtig wie wenn
meine Haare sind definitiv zu kurz wie
gehen wir jetzt vor ich nehme meine
Haare mach einen Zopf dann Spray ich so
ein bisschen mein frottiert kam an ich
glaube so heißt der nagelt mich nicht
draufsetzen dann wird quasi der Ansatz
so geplustert ist der schön griffig ist
dann Klippen wir unsere Haarteile auf
und klemmen sie fest und so habe ich ihn
auch Verlängerung ja das ist das ist
perfekt ah
nee das ist leider nur
kurzen Helm auf jetzt Magic letzte
Strähne mach jetzt mal den Fehler und
kennen sie vorsichtig durch boah wow das
Problem mit mir und Haarverlängerung ist
dass ich so viele davon brauche dass ich
hier immer so ein dicken Helm habe damit
sie halt natürlich lang Aussehen ich
habe halt sehr sehr viele Haare deswegen
haben auch die letzten Extension die ich
mir dann mal rein gemacht habe 2000 €
gekostet weil es so viel Haare aussieht
so witzig gerade aus ja und jetzt kommen
die iconic Flechten Zöpfe
[Musik]
gut die Flächen Zöpfe sind jetzt nicht
perfekt aber das kann ich ja noch mal
nachjustieren jetzt kommt das Pony und
diesmal habe ich mir noch
professionelles Equipment geholt und
eine Nagelschere organisiert denn die
Bastelschere war mir echt ein bisschen
zu reitig hat auch so ein Pony das geht
so so seitlich also muss man in der
Mitte erstmal was abschneiden
also meine harte Tutorials werden hier
immer skurriler und dann geht man halt
so in der Seite schräg runter ich glaube
es nicht wie ich da einfach so Hardcore
hier durchschneiden kann
aber das ist kein Problem wir haben
nämlich unsere seltsame Schere von der
ich absolut nicht weiß was sie tut aber
das ist wichtig und richtig
es muss kürzer
ich liebe es ich liebe es mit den
Klamotten
[Applaus]
oh Gott aber nicht ein T-Shirt tragen wo
Pussy drauf steht deswegen war ich
shoppen
[Musik]
das Problem ist aber ich habe unterwegs
nur so Freizeitklamotten gefunden die
sie tragen würde deswegen habe ich noch
ein bisschen was bestellt ich wollte
jetzt nicht das Outfit vom Abschlussball
nehmen denn da hat sie ja auch so eine
Frisur aber ich habe die Schuluniform
versucht nachzustellen angekommen ist ne
ich hoffe mal alles mit eurer
Nagelschere könnt ihr natürlich auch
eure Pakete öffnen
weiter oben wird am coolsten ich habe
nämlich so ein Hemd gefunden was kein
Hemd ist einfach nur so ein Brustteil
aber es hat genau den Kragen wie von
winstase Schuluniform so ein Wunder und
äh wir ziehen uns an
okay keine Chilis zeigen so cool denn
jetzt kommt nämlich noch was anderes
obendrauf und zwar dieser untere
Pullover ja
[Musik]
und jetzt brauchen wir natürlich noch
einen Jackett das Jacket ist von Vero
Moda das hat so ein festeren Stoff und
nicht so eine komische Seide oder so
weil die Uniform ist ja auch nicht und
Business Blazer sondern eher so
oh mein Gott oh mein gott sieht das cool
aus boah das ist das beste Halloween
Kostüm was ich jemals haben werde
gekauft das ist der einzige fail also
die Krawatte die ich bestellt habe
sollte auf jeden Fall nicht so sein die
Arbeiten mit dem was wir haben natürlich
bekommt sie noch lange schwarze Socken
und solche würde nur treffen
sich die Sachen gesucht habe aber jemand
Prada gedacht
[Musik]
[Applaus]
für die nächste Season mitmachen
[Musik]
Reaktion sie auf mein Umstyling hat sie
ist ja eigentlich die Umstyling
mein Arm wird klar Kelly erreicht man
nie per Telefon in dieser
Bildschirmaufnahme rufe ich Naomi an
oh oh ich wollte nur fragen wann ich
heute Abend kommen soll
ich transformiere ich mich in westday
war gerade gesagt habe ich sie aus wie
ein stay eine Person kann ich noch
anrufen jetzt rufen wir bei Anja
[Musik]
ja tolle Reaktion aber Leute wir haben
2023 und da muss ich natürlich einen
tiktok tanzen diesem Outfit sonst ist es
nicht wirklich passiert also let's go
oh mein Gott wie werde ich das denn
lernen können ähm was sind denn auch
diese neue Generation was was können die
das alles so gut
okay ja ja ja da haben die alle Tanz
plötzlich studiert
Dinge ich habe es verstanden aber
umsetzen kann ich es einfach nicht
[Musik]
diese tiktoker oder die das alle machen
die haben so eine
selbstbewusste Körpersprache da fragt
man sich wirklich woher
[Musik]
jetzt ich spüre jetzt ist es
jetzt ist es
[Musik]
tiktok angucken
oh mein Gott
junge so macht man das in 2023
und das war's eigentlich auch schon ich
zeige euch jetzt noch die zwei Oberteile
die gekauft habe die mich voll an one
sale erinnert haben und die sie auch so
ähnlich in der Serie getragen hat und
dann machen wir die Kiste hier zu okay
leute ihr seid nicht ready dafür
ich darf nicht so happy gucken ich liebe
diesen Style also die Schuhe mit der
Strumpfhose und der Rock und dann dieses
Oberteil da drüber verwandle mich jetzt
einfach nur der ist eigentlich noch mehr
sie
wir beenden das Video da wo es
angefangen hat und falls ihr meinen
tiktok Kanal noch nicht kennt dann
checke mal aus atmalwanne und folgt mir
auf Instagram vielen Dank ich habe euch
alle ganz doll lieb tschüssi